[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
lentement mais sûrement nos réserves
pétrolières s'épuisent ingénieurs et
scientifiques réfléchissent à d'autres
moyens d'alimenter nos villes en énergie
le soleil fusion nucléaire
le vent et des architectes trouve des
solutions innovantes pour les mettre en
oeuvre
il a fallu sept ans au roi salomon pour
construire son temple en sept ans dans
cette même région le moyen-orient c'est
toute une ville qui va émerger du désert
une ville dédiée au développement
durable
elle comprendra un centre de recherche
international sur les énergies
renouvelables et son campus des sites de
production axée sur l'énergie solaire et
1500 d'entreprises employant 40 mille
personnes elle fonctionnera un niveau
zéro d'émission de co2 rendra superflu
l' usage de la voiture produira sa
propre électricité
[Musique]
c'est là un défi immense et même un
double défi car cette ville nouvelle
doit être écologique jusque dans sa
construction le tra lité carbone et zéro
déchet sur le chantier cette cité modèle
sera achevé en 2016 et s'appellera
masdar la source en arabe
abou dhabi est le plus vaste des émirats
du golfe persique et le plus prospère
dans les années 1950
ce n'était qu'un petit royaume en plein
désert il est devenue une métropole
richissime avec l'avènement du pétrole
abu dhabi lee posséderait 8 % des
réserves pétrolifères mondiale ses
exportations de pétrole représentent
aujourd'hui les deux tiers de son
économie
ce pétrole qui coule à flots on en use
ici sans mesure air conditionné en
permanence grosses voitures dessalement
de l'eau de mer gourmands en énergie
l'émirat d'abou dhabi est un petit pays
mais un gros pollueurs
c'est à deux pas de ce paradis du
pétrole que masdar va surgir de terre
comme une sorte de vitrine pour les
technologies propres
comment ce projet a vu le jour en 2006
le gouvernement d'abou dhabi a pris
conscience que ce pays avait une
mauvaise empreinte écologique qu'il
faisait partie de ceux qui émettent le
plus de co2 on a donc décidé d'agir
passer d'une économie basée sur le
pétrole et le gaz à une économie fondée
sur des énergies renouvelables et des
techniques innovantes
le projet de masdar est l'outil qui
devrait nous aider à atteindre cet
objectif sanada remède est chargé de
mettre en oeuvre la phase 1 de la
construction le masdar institute of
science & technology un centre de
recherche et d'enseignement dédiée aux
énergies renouvelables sur le campus de
l'institut
on se déplacera grâce au personal rapid
transit de petits véhicules propulsés
par l'électricité produite à masdar
[Musique]
le centre de recherche et son campus
seront édifiés en deux phases la
première la phase 1a prévoit la
construction de deux laboratoires de
recherche et de 101 logements pour des
étudiants de troisième cycle
[Musique]
au rez-de-chaussée une cantine des
salles de cours des magasins et une
chapelle
le bâtiment phare du campus sera la
bibliothèque avec sa coupole blanche
édifier cette ville éco efficaces qui
accueillera quarante cinq mille
habitants en 2016 est un pari d'autant
plus difficile que le chantier lui-même
doit répondre aux critères du
développement durable et sanad n'ai que
18 mois pour mener à bien sa mission
marc
il a rendez vous ce matin avec marc burg
pour voir comment avancent les
fondations
[Musique]
ok c'est comment ça se passe pas mal du
tout vous en êtes où cette nuit on a
travaillé comme jamais on a fait une
vingtaine de pieds là on vient juste de
commencer à creuser pour coller une
nouvelle série de vingt pieux masdar
sera érigé sur une ancienne palmeraie de
six kilomètres carrés bien qu'il soit
situé dans le désert
ce terrain est trop proche de la mer
pour qu'on puisse creuser sans risque et
d'infiltration si bien que les bâtiments
seront construits en superstructure sur
une dalle à 9 mètres de hauteur pour
assurer la portance de cette dalle
il faut d'abord coulé des pieux à 20
mètres de profondeur on fore un trou et
on et glisse une armature métallique
autour de laquelle on vient couler du
béton
[Musique]
pas n'importe quel béton d'ailleurs
puisque le chantier de masdar doit
utiliser autant possible des matériaux
propres
[Musique]
on estime que la production du 6 mois
ordinaire à l'échelon de la planète est
responsable de 5% des émissions de co2
marc burg et son équipe ont fait un
compromis moitié six mois ordinaire
moitié ggbs un mélange de ciment et de
scorer deux hauts fourneaux
[Musique]
alors ce mélange de béton c'est bien du
béton durable du gbs écologique à 60%
donc il est bien dans les normes
requises pour une ville durable
oui c'est ça
pour respecter le calendrier mark bell
devra de couler douce que par jour
pendant les cinq prochaines semaines
vous en êtes à combien de pieux ça doit
être le 138e en moins de dix jours exact
138 pieux excellent
mark sanad doivent réaliser la phase 1
en respectant l'échéancier et le cahier
des charges c'est si l'on veut un galop
d'essai avant de passer à la
construction de la ville tout entière
[Musique]
à londres se trouve le siège du cabinet
d'architecturé d'urbanisme foster and
partners qui a conçu les plans de toute
la ville de masdar est réalisé pour
l'instant les maquettes de la première
phase
sanad et mohamed noir à un des
concepteurs du projet de masdar au
rendez vous chez foster and partners
avec deux architectes
l'idée est d'essayer de créer pour
l'ensemble du campus un point de
convergence
un centre qui serait le coeur du projet
l'emplacement de ce choeur dans
l'infrastructure urbaine est
fondamentale le plan directeur de masdar
est tout à fait inédit un ensemble
urbain très concentré construit sur une
plateforme et écologiquement
irréprochable on a ici
l'une des clés du concept général de
masdar l'ensemble très étudié deux
ruelles étroites donnant sur des
patients si on dégage de l'espace
larchitecture d'abou dhabi s'inspire des
villes américaines grandes avenues baies
vitrées esplanade une aberration sous un
tel climat en termes de consommation
énergétique
traditionnellement dans les villes du
moyen-orient
on privilégie les ruelles ombragées les
tours avant les cours intérieures
les architectes britanniques se sont en
quelque sorte réapproprier le schéma de
la médina qui permet de tirer parti des
variations thermiques naturel le climat
désertique d'abou dhabi se caractérise
par des écarts thermiques de 8 à 10
degrés entre le jour et la nuit à masdar
on va exploiter ce phénomène sous les
arcades les zones ombragées murs et
plafonds sont faits d'un béton très
dense
la nuit ses parois se refroidisse et
dans la journée leur température
initiale étant inférieure à celle de
l'air ambiant
elle absorbe les calories de
l'atmosphère pour rafraîchir les rues et
les espaces publics on érigera une tour
avant utilisant la circulation naturelle
de l'air des capteurs détectent la
direction du vent et ouvre des bouches
d'aération les flux d'air frais ils
descendent par la seule différence de
pression
[Musique]
la quasi totalité des besoins
énergétiques de masdar seront assurés
par des panneaux solaires qui
recouvriront 80% des toits du centre de
recherche
c'est à dessein que les panneaux des
bords de des toitures au dessus des rues
pour ombrager celle ci mais aussi pour
que les habitants sachent d'où provient
cette énergie mais le choix des panneaux
sur le toit ne fait pas l'unanimité je
me demande si c'est indispensable de
poser des panneaux photovoltaïques sur
un aussi joli toi il est vraiment beau
ce toit avec sa forme de coquille assez
emblématique et on recouvrirait avec ses
panneaux si on ne le fait pas on laisse
passer une opportunité en une
opportunité de poser des panneaux en
termes de superficie et s'il ya ne
serait-ce qu'un centimètre carré de 300
panneaux solaires moi je suis un homme
mort à mon avis il faut revoir ça ce
sera yves de franchement ça va faire un
très vilain patchou option recouvre ce
toit de panneaux doit éviter que ce soit
laid donc il faut choisir la technologie
les matériaux adéquats pour le toit en
alliant l'efficacité à la beauté puisque
le but est de faire quelque chose
d'emblématique oui ce sera le bâtiment
emblématique de la phase un rat
[Musique]
la construction durable est une idée
encore neuf qui doit être explicite et
aux entreprises venues travailler sur le
projet de masdar
c'est le rôle de mec sidorov et lloyds
clark donc 3 go pourquoi un projet vert
ces sujets d'aujourd'hui neutre en co2
mohamed vous savez ce que ça veut dire
non c'est normal neutre en co2 est un
terme un peu vague sur le quai les
spécialistes eux mêmes ne sont pas très
au clair ce que nous voulons c'est
réduire l'énergie utilisée pour
construire des bâtiments employés des
matériaux propres et faire en sorte que
ces bâtiments fonctionne en émettant le
moins de co2 possible
c'est comme ça qu'on aura un bilan
carbone neutre
c'est ce que veut dire neutre en co2
zéro déchet ça c'est clair
en fait c'est assez simple il faut
recycler ou réutilisés chaque fois qu'on
peut tout la question des déchets réside
là dedans il ya des poubelles partout
des bennes pour les matériaux
recyclables
vous avez tout cela un peu étonné c'est
pour ça que je demande si tout le monde
est d'accord
vous avez des questions votre premier
audit aura lieu fin janvier
ce qu'ils voulaient six semaines pour
tout mettre en place pour que tout soit
parfait sur le chantier un chantier
écologique est ce réalisable mais guy ne
le sera qu'à l'issue de ce premier audit
la première grue télescopique de masdar
bien être monté
ces grues géantes qui font parfois 50
mètres de haut permettent de mettre en
place des éléments préfabriqués coffrage
ou colonnes
elle sert aussi à déplacer les surplus
de matériaux vers les zones de stockage
ou de recyclage avant d'installer les
grues les ingénieurs font un plan précis
de leur rayon d'action et calcul ou les
positionner pour couvrir entièrement le
chantier il faudra cinq de ses bus rue
pour la seule réalisation du centre de
recherche et de son campus
les quelques 900 pieux servant de
fondation à la dalle sont presque tous
couler on passe maintenant à la dalle
elle même et aux colonnes le cahier des
charges de masdar veut que le processus
de construction lui même soit aussi
écologique que possible m -cd raf et
lloyd clark montrent à leurs chefs pris
ce but ce qu'ils ont fait jusqu'à
présent sur le chantier
vous voyez les têtes de pieux qui ont
été réparés et ici les pieux qu'il va
falloir réduire parce qu'ils sont
légèrement trop et là bas aussi
ensuite il y a le coffrage qui se
montent sur les têtes de pieux et que
deviennent les gravats une fois c'était
de pieux démoli les gravats de béton
sont envoyés dans la zone de
valorisation des déchets pour être
réutilisés tout le béton est recyclé
nous perdons rien donc dès que les têtes
de pieux sont démantelés les gravats
viennent dans cette zone et sont
concassés très bien très bien mais c'est
énorme l'engin fonctionne à l'essence
c'est là encore un facteur important
d'émissions de co2 dont on doit tenir
compte
et dites moi un peu ce qu'on fait pour
améliorer les émissions de co2 sur ces
engins le bio diesel ou les hybrides bio
diesel électricité on en est où
pour le moment c'est du diesel normal
mais l'année prochaine on devrait avoir
du biocarburant 505% mais il y a des
machines plus récente qui doivent faire
mieux que ça vous croyez pas bien sûr
mais le 5 % à l'avantagé de convenir à
tous les ans gens qui travaillent sur le
chantier
très juste on pourrait donc amener du
bio carburant pur et faire le mélange
sur place que tous les engins fonctionne
aux 5 % voire mieux ça c'est possible
pour certains d'entre eux on regarde
aussi du côté des nouvelles technologies
on discute avec d'autres fournisseurs
au lieu des vieux engins au diesel on va
trouver pour ici des systèmes plus
écologique
on a spécifié je crois que tous les
engins du chantier devait être conforme
aux normes européennes d'émission euro
euro 4 oui c'est pas le cas de celui ci
mais c'est un ange en hockey surnom oui
c'est provisoire
tous les nouveaux engins qui arrive
maintenant sur le chantier sont
conformes aux normes euro iv et sont
aussi récents que possible très bien
très bien ça devrait s'améliorer
sanad se rend lui aussi sur le site
accompagné de marc pour voir comment
avancent la construction les premières
colonnes ont été posées sur les
fondations
vous voyez la première grue télescopique
est monté en bonne chose de faite
il nous reste juste à installer le
courant les câbles et le treuil
la semaine dernière on a bien bien
avancé 9 ou 10 pieux c'est très
satisfaisant
on a atteint notre rythme de croisière
maintenant en effet l'ossature du campus
commence à prendre forme
la phase 1 race se divise en quatre
sections quatre zones
ce que vous voyez là ce sont les
premiers poteaux avec des armatures le
coulage complètement terminée
ils font partie de la zone 2 la zone
d'habitation
[Musique]
la zone 1 ce sont les l'amo et les
salles de cours
on voit ici la première série de colonne
de la zone
[Musique]
au fond il y aura la bibliothèque la
zone 3 et dans cette direction là où on
voit les grues c'est la zone 4 ils
constituent le reste de la plate forme
avec tout ce qui est au niveau de la rue
[Musique]
la ville de masdar coûtera en tout 22
milliards de dollars que le gouvernement
d'abou dhabi financent en grande partie
sous la forme d'un prêt il faut donc
qu'elles soient non seulement écologique
mais rentable d'où le zèle avec lequel
sa natte contrôler les budgets
vous pouvez m'envoyer ça par e-mail
bien sûr donc ça c'est un devis pour
pour le mobilier sa figure dans les
données prévisionnelles de vie numéro
deux avec les coûts de fabrication
c'est un montant inacceptable ce sera
refusé j'aime autant vous le dire tout
de suite pendant que sa note l'inquiète
des dépassements de budgets sur le
terrain mark bowden a un autre souci
salut les gars savent à la sécurité
lunettes
plusieurs dizaines d'ouvriers sont morts
accidentellement ces dernières années
dans les émirats arabes unis c'est
pourquoi marque est aussi insistant
voudrais te confier un petit travail il
faudrait installer quelques marches pour
monter des marches un accès de chercher
un chef d'equipe qui parlent anglais tu
veux pour que je puisse lui expliquez
vous faut de vraies marche sinon mon
temps comme ça vous risquez de tomber en
arrière
il faut un escalier comprendre partout
ici d'accord
marquez chef du chantier depuis 29 ans
c'est son premier poste moyen-orient où
il est parfois difficile d'imposer les
normes de sécurité rigoureuses auquel il
est habitué
le chantier de masdar emploie des
centaines d'ouvriers des américains des
indiens des chinois et il importe que
les consignes de sécurité soient bien
comprises par tous
c'est crucial pour nous travailler en
toute sécurité sur ce chantier que vous
en repartiez sow nex et du raf déploie
autour d'énergie pour pousser les
responsables d'entreprises à diminuer
l'impact environnemental du chantier le
délai de six semaines qu'elle leur avait
octroyé étant écoulé elle procède
aujourd'hui à l'audit de la société emg
l'iphone il est responsable des
questions d'environnement
premier point à vérifier le type de
matériau utilisé les contreplaqués
chinois vous voyez il est pas bien
assemblé on pourra pas l'utiliser
plusieurs fois je vois alors que celui
ci est bon il est très solide
alors vous en avait parlé à celui qui
s'occupe de l'approvisionnement vous
l'avait bien dit de se procurer des
matériaux de qualité écologique est
conforme aux normes iso
vous avez mentionné tout cela oui on l'a
précisé par email aux responsables des
approvisionnements et à la direction et
quand ils choisissent du matériel
surtout du bois faut qu'ils proviennent
de sources écologie on leur donne une
liste des pays qui pratiquent une
exploitation forestière correct c'est ça
la france la finlande la suède
autre point important le recyclage là
bas il ya des gravats de béton
par contre il n'ya pas d'étiquette
indiquant que c'est du béton
hélas les bennes de recyclage elles
viennent d'être vidé à la il ya une
étiquette
oui mais elle est à l'envers comme ça
c'est mieux
bon il faut entretenir la signalisation
hockey point suivant sur la liste
les déchets dangereux des déchets
dangereux
j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a plus en
plus il ya les fameux panneaux de
particules suspect là dedans non c'est
vrai qu'il faut consommer plein
[Musique]
oui on a tous les restes de fioul
d'huile
tout ce qui ne doit pas pénétré dans le
sol les restes de peinture
on doit s'en débarrasser comme il faut
tout ce qui est huit peintures diluant
les dealers oui les met dans des sacs
renforcer on les sort d'ici pareil pour
les gants soulier oui pareil donc
plusieurs déchets n'ont pas été stockés
correctement pas assez correctement je
vous remets un pour chaque point de sa
liste mais donne une note à l'entreprise
et calculs informatiquement son
empreinte écologique
alors la société being aura-t-elle une
bonne note globale c asseyez-vous alors
disons que dans l'ensemble sur le site
les choses sont faites comme il faut
mais je mets quelques réserves pour la
zone des déchets en tout cas tout est
bien trier vous avez compris ce qu'il
fallait faire les ouvriers du chantier
l'ont compris aussi et ça c'est très
bien
soulagés 1
alors continuez comme ça continue à
faire du bon boulot
ouais on va faire encore mieux voilà
très bien et le mois prochain on sera
encore plus sévère
[Musique]
je m'amusais à questionner les gens
quels sont les deux objectifs de masdar
il répondait la durabilité et moi je
disais non sa neutralité carbone et zéro
déchet il faut réfléchir à ça et à ce
qu'on fait au quotidien pour y parvenir
est-ce que je passe mon temps à harceler
les gens non ce n'est pas dans mon
tempérament
mais ils savent que je les observe et
que s'ils font quelque chose de travers
je vais venir les trouver tout contrite
ils ont mauvaise conscience et ils me
diront qu'ils n'ont pas eu le temps
il ya des jours où j'en ai marre c'est
pareil pour les gens qui contrôlent le
planning je suis sûr qu'il ya des jours
où il envoie tout balader en se disant
on n'aura jamais fini à temps moi il
m'arrive aussi de nous dire la
durabilité on n'y arrivera jamais tout
le monde a ses moments de découragement
mais si un jour ça ne va pas le
lendemain ça s'arrange il faut l'espérer
tout au moins
avec des budgets et des délais très
serrés meg est obligé parfois de faire
des compromis mais les deux points clés
du cahier des charges écologique de
masdar bilan carbone neutre et recyclage
des déchets qu ont déjà été pris comme
modèle pour d'autres chantiers du
moyen-orient comme ici ces coffrages son
fait à 90% d'acier recyclé
lacie présente l'avantagé de pouvoir
être indéfiniment recyclé sans perdre
ses propriétés en utilisant cet acier à
masdar ont réduit nettement l'impact
écologique du chantier
en effet la fabrication d'une tonne
d'acier recyclé engendre 80 % de co2 en
moins que la fabrication d'une tonne
d'acier normale à partir de minerai de
fer
[Musique]
abou dhabi la température varie entre 21
degrés divers et plus de 40 degrés à
l'ombre l'été
l'atmosphère est en outre très humide ce
qui rend la chaleur encore plus
étouffante
en toute logique on envisageait de
capter l'énergie solaire pour alimenter
masdar 90 % de son électricité
proviendra d'une part des panneaux
photovoltaïques installés sur les toits
d'autre part d'une grande centrale
solaire d'une capacité de 10 mégawatts
[Musique]
mais paradoxalement les panneaux
solaires s'accommode mal de ce climat
désertique
leur efficacité est réduit par le sable
et la poussière qui se dépose et une
température excessive peut altérer les
performances de certains modules
samir abu zayd installe à l'essai
différents panneaux afin de choisir les
plus performantes
[Musique]
on est en train de poser les supports en
béton pour les panneaux et la semaine
prochaine en installera les structures
et les panneaux que dieu vous donne du
courage pour les aligner
voyez on les met en ligne on est niveau
ou parfaitement vous continuez avec le
reste des panneaux en alignant comme ça
s'il me reste je les pose au bout de
cette rangée exactement mais en gardant
la même distance
ce matin on s'est dit qu'il valait mieux
les laisser ici puisque on en aura
besoin après
[Musique]
dans cette centrale expérimentale il ya
quarante panneaux qui viennent de 33
fabricants différents de pays aussi
divers que les etats-unis la norvège
l'espagne japon la chine et taïwan
l'énergie produite pendant ces tests
sera réinjectée dans le réseau
électrique local
mais la manoeuvre est un peu compliquée
générateur du système installé à
l'extérieur est en courant continu
on ne peut pas le faire passer
directement sur le réseau qui est lui en
courant alternatif
alors chaque panneau est relié à un nom
du leur qui convertit en courant
alternatif le courant continu générés
par le soleil avant de l'envoyer au
réseau local
ici vous voyez des wattmètre qui indique
combien de watts fourni en ce moment
chaque panneau vous remarqué que les
chiffres sont variables
certains sont élevés d'autres bas
normalement ils devraient tous syndiqués
1000 watts mais comme il est 3 heures de
l'après midi et que le soleil ne donne
plus directement sur les panneaux ils
produisent moins d'énergie
[Musique]
il faut pour respecter les délais que le
chantier tourne 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 avec des équipes qui se relaient
mais vient le moment où il faut
concilier contraintes matérielles et
traditions religieuses
[Musique]
bon nombre des ouvriers de masdar sont
musulmans et observent le jeûne du
ramadan ils peuvent continuer à
travailler mais sans manger du lever au
coucher du soleil et sans boire même à
midi par 42 degrés
[Musique]
sanad observe le jeu ne lui aussi pour
tous elle est là dès 8h et travaille dix
heures par jour tant la pression est
forte
il s'est engagé à ce que le campus soit
prêt dans les temps pour accueillir les
étudiants
c'est une bonne expérience de jeune et
toute la journée je trouve ça me rend
plus fort je suis sur le terrain
accablés de chaleur en train d'observer
ce travail sous différents angles de vue
de regarder ces ouvriers qui passent des
heures sous le soleil
je me sens comme eux je participe sans
boire et sans manger
le ramadan a débuté il ya une semaine il
se trouve que ça na doit faire un
rapport à son chef mohammed nehoua rats
vous pouvez me dire où en est la
construction jusqu'à hier nous avons
coulé 27 pieux est monté neuf colonnes
la dalle sera prête en novembre
actuellement nous avons 3 115 ouvriers
sur le chantier
l'équipe de jour et équipe de nuit s'il
travaille 24h sur 24 il va vous falloir
au moins 700 ou 800 ouvriers pour y
arriver je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous fin octobre nous aurons 500
étudiants 500 ouvriers ils vous ont fait
800 si non vous n'y arriverez pas vous
n'avez fait que neuf colonnes pour
l'instant c'est peu c'est vrai c'est
très peu mais le travail du coffrage
marchait très bien
ils le font en général la nuit le matin
quand l'autre équipe arrive il coule le
béton donc le coffrage avance bien
je pense que ça ira quand on aura plus
de main d'oeuvre
quel impact a eu le ramadan sur
l'avancée des travaux vous savez qu'il y
à des ouvriers musulmans sur le chantier
le rendement a baissé parce qu'il jeunes
ils ont soif
j'ai demandé au chef d'equipe qu'on
aménage des zones où les ouvriers
musulmans puissent se reposer
[Musique]
moi même je suis moins efficace vous
savez on a soif tout le temps il fait
chaud je suis dehors dans la chaleur je
rentre je transpire
donc c'est un peu difficile à la fin de
la journée il y a le résultat le
couronnement de l'effort qu'on a
accompli en travaillant douze heures par
jour en y mettant tout son coeur tout
son esprit sa famille sa vie sociale et
tout ça pour être dans les temps
faire le centre de recherche et le
campus dans les délais ce sera notre
plus belle récompense à la fin
à matane
[Musique]
à
en huit mois les 922 options ont été
coulés et les colonnes érigé par dessus
les ouvriers vont pouvoir construire la
dalle qui va accueillir le campus sous
cette dalle il y aura les circuits
électriques les systèmes de
refroidissement et le personal rapid
transit au dessus la bibliothèque les
laboratoires les appartements les
commerces
on
près d'un millier d'ouvriers travaillent
pour l'instant à masdar en équipe de
jour et de nuit
la réalisation de la phase 1a étant déjà
bien avancé l'équipe de nuit a commencé
à travailler sur la phase 1b la
construction d'un local pour une
association d'étudiants une salle de gym
et d'une piscine découverte
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'issue des tests samir a finalement
choisi des panneaux provenant de chine
et d'allemagne pour équiper sa centrale
photovoltaïque il en expose les plans
aux ingénieurs la centrale sera
installée dans le coin nord-ouest du
site
elle s'étendra sur deux cent mille
mètres carrés qui ont déjà été délimitée
on commencera à clôturer le terrain et à
faire un plan d'installation des
panneaux le mois prochain
la pose des panneaux s'achèvera en
janvier
aujourd'hui samir va visiter le site
avec khaled le maître d'oeuvre de la
centrale le drapeau rouge c'est les
drapeaux rouges ce sont les limites du
terrain c'est vraiment immense ce sera
la plus grande de la région je vois à
peine les autres bornes la helaba
personne n'a jamais créé une aussi
grande centrale photovoltaïque
malgré les efforts de sanad et de toutes
les équipes
la construction de la phase 1 est en
retard de quelques mois notamment à
cause de certains critères concernant le
développement durable comme les
isolations thermiques essentiel pour
l'éco efficacité de masdar
notre pari le plus important c'est le
respect du cahier des charges des
laboratoires il faut que nous soyons
certains d'atteindre les objectifs
d'efficacité énergétique pour les
façades des laboratoires et des
immeubles d'habitation nous essayons
d'obtenir un certain coefficient
d'isolation pour la performance
énergétique
les façades des bâtiments doivent être
parfaitement isolé pour absorber le
moins de chaleur possible sous ces
climats très chaud on dépense énormément
d'énergie pour rafraîchir l'intérieur
des bâtiments
si l'on veut que masdar soit une ville
neutre en co2 il faut qu'elles
présentent la meilleure performance
énergétique possible dans les
laboratoires équipés en matériel fragile
la température doit impérativement être
constante
voici ce que les designers de foster and
partners ont imaginé
la première couche de la façade
transparente mais très résistante est
fait d'un produit proche du téflon qui
empêche le sable et la poussière d'y
adhérer
mais pas nous suivant est une zone
tampon thermique la troisième couche est
une feuille de papier d'aluminium qui
réverbère la chaleur tout en reflétant
la lumière du jour dans les ruelles
enfin vient à panneaux hermétique
parfaitement isolant
[Musique]
les architectes londoniens ont demandé
que soit construit une maquette pour
s'assurer que c'est une idée novatrice
s'avère aussi intéressante que
l'imaginent tant du point de vue
énergétique qu esthétique sur le
chantier une équipe travaille depuis
plusieurs jours à cette maquette
grandeur nature un immeuble d'habitation
avec sa façade pour la conception est
similaire à celle des laboratoires
elle est tout juste terminée quand tu
arrives de londres les responsables du
cabinet de design et d'architecturé
foster and partners
gérard et wendel chef de projet
david nelson directeur général eros
palmer architectes sanad est là pour les
accueillir et discuter avec eux de ce
modèle qui préfigure avec quelques mois
d'avancé ce que sera le campus de masdar
je suis très content de mon choix
cet aspect cuivre et regarder la texture
cette incroyable parois hautes
performances et la troisième couche
celle qui est à l'intérieur
cette couche qui empêche simplement la
paroisse cuivre et de recevoir
directement la lumière du soleil les
murs des immeubles d'habitation sont
aussi esthétique que fonctionnel leurs
façades se compose là encore de quatre
couches la première un mélange de sable
du désert et de béton armé de fibre de
verre protège les couches inférieures
des rayons solaires directs
la seconde une zone tampon thermique qui
réduit la chaleur rayonner la troisième
et la paroisse haute performance en
aluminium couleur cuivre à 90 % recyclé
elle dévient la chaleur et assurent
l'étanchéité à l'air de la façade
enfin la quatrième couche est un isolant
de 25 cm d'épaisseur
en tout cas on va prendre cette couleur
elle est bien cette couleur non celle
qui est légèrement plus foncée oui c'est
la mieux c'est la plus belle couleur
c'est très vert langton qui doit
réaliser les panneaux composant les
façades des bâtiments d'habitation d'ici
trois mois
il devra fournir laissant un panneau
nécessaire pour tout le bâtiment
vous aurez le temps c'est un peu serré
comme délai je suis le seul à être dans
les temps ici c'est vrai on pourrait
peut-être préparer un panneau le regard
d'ensemble on donne le feu vert et puis
on passe à la production parfait et ça
c'est la largeur réelle de la rue oui on
a fait en sorte que ce soit fidèle à la
réalité c'est la rue la plus étroite les
rues ne feront que quatre mètres
cinquante de large de façon à être peu
exposées au soleil ou à l'extrême
chaleur comme dans les villes
traditionnelles l'orientation du centre
de recherches sud est nord ouest lui
assure de l'ombre presque toute la
journée
[Musique]
l'autre jour je travaillais là bas et je
transpirait à grosses gouttes est arrivé
ici ça allait mieux c'est ça oui j'étais
carrément gelés c'est incroyable
six mois plus tard les panneaux des
façades sorte de lusine trésor est dans
les temps comme promis
[Musique]
m l'ornais la marque bogues
le chef de chantier supervise la pose
des panneaux des appartements du campus
il pèse près de deux tonnes chacun
[Musique]
tout le monde est sur les nerfs
il suffirait d'une fausse manoeuvre pour
abîmer les plaques de métal coloré situé
derrière chaque panneau qui sont des
pièces maîtresses pour la performance
énergétique
l'opération de pose est délicate mais le
résultat est là des appartements bien
isolée de la chaleur grâce à une façade
qui évoque les moucharabiehs de
l'architecturé arabe traditionnel
[Musique]
de son côté meg poursuit sa course à la
neutralité carbone elle passe en revue
tous les matériaux utilisés sur le
chantier composition provenance et
moyens de transport par lequel ils sont
arrivés à abou dhabi ça c'est juillet
alors voyons les matériaux en juillet on
a fait le point sur les foreuses et les
coffrages sur le chantier on a utilisé
que du béton et les armatures en faire
elle examine aussi les déplacements de
tous les employés de masdar et
d'élimination des déchets alors les
voyages d'affaires on a tous des détails
pour juillet il y a eu quelques réunions
à londres et il a fallu aller en chine
aussi comme ça on peut facilement
mesurer l'empreinte carbone de chaque
voyage
exactement
alors le dernier oui les déchets les
seuls qui aient quitté le site sont les
eaux usées les déchets toxiques et les
déchets alimentaires pour éviter
d'attirer les rats tous ces chiffres
traitez-moi par mois révèle le bilan
carbone du chantier indique entame aig
quelle est l'empreinte écologique des
bâtiments de la phase 1 pendant leur
construction
ça nous fait un total de 63,9 tonnes de
carbone 63,9 d'accord
[Musique]
dans ses tableaux mec fera figure et
bien sûr la mesure compensatoire mis en
place par samir la réinjection dans le
réseau local de l'électricité produite
[Musique]
l'aménagement d'une centrale solaire est
déjà en soi une belle réalisation
mais un autre ça me rend former une
équipe locale capable à l'avenir
d'installer d'autres centrales dans les
émirats
elle est gigantesque
c'est la première centrale solaire de ce
type dans tout le moyen orient
la première ferme photovoltaïque
non seulement nous fourniront de
l'électricité à la ville mais l'un des
objectifs de cette centrale est de créer
le savoir faire dans ce domaine
abu dhabi c'est mon invention et j'en
suis fier
c'est moi qui suis à l'initiative de ce
projet et je vais le voir se réaliser
dieu nous a donné tellement de
ressources à exploiter
il nous faut simplement faire marcher
notre cerveau pour utiliser ce que dieu
a mis à notre disposition et c'est ce
que nous faisons ici non mais mieux vaut
tard que jamais c'est un investissement
pour l'avenir
mon
[Musique]
une
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant
j'adore
voilà tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a toujours des retards des
impondérables mais le chantier continue
d'avancer jour après jour
porté par cette équipe motivée qui veut
croire en un avenir durable
et
[Applaudissements]
de ce désert sanad marque les ouvriers
auront fait sortir en 18 mois
deux laboratoires de recherche sur les
énergies renouvelables sans un
appartement pour des étudiants de
troisième cycle de toutes nationalités
et une version moderne de la
traditionnelle tournée vans
[Musique]
ils en sont à présent à monter le toit
de la bibliothèque
[Musique]
dans quelques mois une fois les
finitions terminée l'institut de
sciences et de technologie ouvrira ses
portes aux premiers étudiants
il est trop tôt pour savoir si le projet
de masdar aura un impact sur l'empreinte
écologique globale d'abou dhabi mais
sanada remède est convaincu que les
compétences acquises et les leçons
apprises durant la première phase de la
construction changeront forcément les
choses
je suis impliqué dans ce projet depuis
le tout début j'ai participé au choix
des architectes des consultants des
entreprises et des sous traitants
j'ai fait face à toutes les difficultés
applaudi à tous les succès j'étais là
pour chaque ratage chaque triomphe
chaque événement marquant c'est le
projet de ma vie je veux léguer cette
réalisation mes enfants j'ai deux
enfants et je tiens absolument à ce
qu'ils sachent que j ai participé chaque
fois que je passerai devant masdar je
leur montrerai ce que nous avons fait
c'est l'avenir que nous construirons ici
cette réalisation encouragera
certainement les futurs décideurs
politiques à exporter ce projet dans le
monde entier
il s'agit de construire non seulement
des bâtiments durables mais un monde
durable
[Musique]